THE PLAYOFF SPOT.
YOU GET THE FEELING THAT THE
ISLANDERS DON'T WANT TO CHANGE
ALSO
PENALTY.
YOU DON'T NEED IT.
PUCKS IN
IN THE MIDDLE.
ALEX I FOLLOW OFF A
SNIPE!
IND THE GOAL, LOSTPUCK CAME FRE.
ANZE KOPITAR COMES AWAY WITH ISS
SETTLE THINGS DOWN.
FIRST EARLIER TODAY.
THE CONTROLLED BY THE
KINGS.
>> OFFENSIVEOUNG MAN.
THIS WILL BEAME THING TO DO IS E
CLEARING.
THAT'S WHAT HE SAVED BY PETERSE!
FLUSHING THE LEATHER.N
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THIS. ICE. YON
THE GAME.
THEIR ONLY GOAL S S STRETCH PASR
THE KINGS, KEEPS
AWAY.
AT.
PERIOD TRIED TO PICKPOCKET HIM
>> T
DOBSON WHIL
WHILE.
NO LONGER WITH THIS
THE SPEED BACK OVER THE INITIAT.
THAT'S WHAT THE KINGS DATED
EARLY.
THAT ALLOWED THE ISLANDERS TO
GETE OF
STICKS.
28 SECONDS